hi I'm Brianna from free code camp and  today we're going to talk about the  basics of computer hardware computers  are made up of four basic parts the  input/output CPU and memory the input is  what you're putting into the computer  think about mouse keyboard microphone  anyway you're giving data into the  computer the output is what you're  watching on your monitor or listening to  on your speakers these can both be any  format like text numbers videos images  what-have-you it doesn't matter the CPU  stands for central processing unit and  that's what we all think of when we  think of a computer  it's what does the functions it's what  runs the software it manipulates the  data the memory is where we store data  and information now the CPU has  exclusive access to this memory you can  get the memory from the input or from  the output without the use of the CPU so  just to review we've got four basic  parts of a computer the input/output CPU  and memory